Tiens !
Joyeux anniversaire !
Oh mais t'es folle,
il ne fallait pas.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est une surprise,
ouvre !
Oh du parfum,
super, merci beaucoup !
Je te fais la bise.
Nan.
C'est...
Je suis pas très tactile, tu sais bien.
Oh oui c'est vrai.
Excuse-moi, j'oublie à chaque fois.
J'ai quelque chose à te dire...
Mais euh... c'est...
C'est pas facile.
Tu sais bien que tu peux tout me dire,
t'es ma soeur, il n'y a pas de secret.
Ça fait longtemps que je veux t'en parler et je...
C'est...
C'est Benoit c'est ça ?
Parce que je sens qu'en ce moment
il n'a plus trop envie de me voir.
J'ai dit un truc qu'il ne fallait pas ou...?
Oui mais non.
C'est Manu ?
Oui parce que la dernière fois
on a eu un petit débat politique
assez houleux je te cache pas,
tu me connais,
et j'ai senti tu sais qu'il était pas euh...
Ouais, t'as senti.
Nan mais il faut que
tu me dises hein parce que...
tu sais moi je sais me remettre en question
et j'ai l'impression qu'en ce moment...
tout le monde me tou...
Tu pues de la gueule.
Hein ?
Voilà.
Je sais, c'est pas facile à entendre,
mais tu sens vraiment
très très très mauvais de la bouche.
Bon... Je vais commander une autre bouteille de vin...?
Nan, ça sert à rien Louise,
le serveur ne reviendra pas,
il ne reviendra jamais
et maintenant tu sais pourquoi.
Tout ton être,
tout ton corps,
tes yeux, tes cheveux, tes pieds,
ta bouche
même tes coudes puent de la gueule.
Il y avait des fleurs sur cette table...
Regarde Louise !
Elles ont fâné depuis que tu es là.
Tu t'es pas demandée
pourquoi tu n'as jamais été piquée par un moustique ?
Ils meurent, Louise !
Les moustiques meurent et ils le savent,
et c'est pour ça qu'ils ne t'approcheront jamais.
T'as commandé des huîtres ?
Regarde un peu, elles fuient !
Les huîtres ont peur de toi !
Et tant qu'on y est,
il faut que je t'avoue quelque chose...
Maman n'est pas morte.
Maman...?
Nan.
C'est juste que son médecin
lui a ordonné de ne plus jamais t'approcher
parce que ses jours étaient comptés !
Il fallait trouver une solution !
Nan mais Louise c'est ouf regarde !
Tu pues tellement de la gueule
que ton haleine on peut la voir quoi !
TU PUES DE LA GUEULE
LOUISE !
Tu comprends ça ?
Tout le monde le sait, tout le monde le sent,
c'est pénible !
On y est.
Mais attendez on n'a fait que 5 mètres là...
Sortez du véhicule.
C'était donc ça...